good afternoon and welcome to the
intimate setting of the Schumann room
named after the roundabout it's our
pleasure to have with us today
commissioner market vista to discuss for
antitrust decisions that we have just
taken commissioner thank you very much
for Cardo today the Commission has taken
four separate decisions to find Asus
Denon and Moran's pioneer and Philips a
total of a hundred and eleven million
euros for breaching EU antitrust rules
these well-known manufacturers of
consumer electronics they put pressure
on entire online retailers to maintain
higher prices they did so during a
period from 2011 to 2015 if a
manufacturer noticed that a particular
online retailer was offering lower
prices than they wanted they would
contact the retailer to tell him to
increase their prices and if the
retailer did not cooperate it would face
sanctions and these sanctions included
as an example with all of the supplies
of the product in question the unknown
online commerce markets it grows rapidly
now it's worth over 500 billion euros in
Europe every year more than half of
Europeans shop online as a result of the
actions taken by the four companies
millions of Europeans faced higher
prices for kitchen appliances hair
dryers netbook computers headphones and
many other products they wanted to buy
from online retailers this is illegal
under EU antitrust rules our decisions
today show that
new competition rules serve to protect
consumers when companies stand in the
way of more prize competition and better
choice one of the big advantages for
consumers in e-commerce is that you can
easily compare prices and shop around to
get a better deal by stopping retailers
from offering lower prices the for
manufacturers denied consumers the full
benefits of e-commerce each of the four
manufacturers individually targeted
online retailers that offers the lowest
prices for their products sometimes the
manufacturers intervenes because of the
price deviation of just one euro other
interventions concern price increases of
more than a hundred euros in any events
the retailers there in any event the
manufacturers wanted retailers to charge
artificially higher retail prices for
their products
we call this resale price maintenance
admits that consumers were worse off
under EU competition rules minimum or
fixed retail price maintenance is
considered a restriction of competition
and will usually be illegal at the same
time our rules enable companies to
justify their behavior if it creates
efficiencies like for example by making
the launch of a new product a success
for the benefit of consumers rules also
offer manufacturers possibilities to
provide support and to protects
brick-and-mortar Shores
neither was the case here all four
companies admitted that there was no
justification for their actions and that
they had broken competition rules in
fact by targeting specific low price
retailers the four manufacturers were
also able
to influence the prices other retailers
charged this is because online retailers
they use pricing algorithms and price
comparison websites to constantly
monitor in real time the prices charged
by their competitors then they adjust
their prices accordingly so if one price
read if one retailer offers lower prices
than others this prompt their
competitors to lower their prices as
well
conversely if that retailer puts their
prices back up others will follow these
practices were in place over a period of
four years and they stopped in 2015 that
was after the commission carried out
unannounced inspections at the premises
of certain manufacturers and started to
look into these practices finally
worried about geographic scope of these
practices the member states affected by
the restrictions were different in each
case Asus applied the practices in
France and Germany
Danone and mehran's intervened in
Germany and the Netherlands Philips
uses practices only in France and
pioneer took action against retailers in
12 countries Belgium Denmark Finland
France Germany Italy the Netherlands
Norway Portugal Spain Sweden and the UK
as I mentioned in all four cases the
companies admitted that they had broken
competition rules they also gave the
Commission additional evidence this
helped us to take a decision and to
tackle the problem for consumers quickly
as a result we decided to reduce the
fines by 50% for pioneer and by 40%
the three other companies pioneer
received a slightly bigger reduction
because they came forward with better
quality evidence than the others this
shows that that as part of our antitrust
incident investigations we are prepared
to recognize effective cooperation by
companies the level of fine reduction
depends on the extents and the timing of
cooperation in the specific case and the
resulting benefits in terms of efficient
procedure and effective enforcement in
the cases decided today the companies
acknowledge the infringement even before
the issuing of a statement of objections
they also provided evidence that added
significant value to what was already in
the Commission's file this allowed for a
number of administrative efficiencies so
this kind of cooperation benefits both
sides and ultimately effective and swift
enforcement of our rules benefit
consumers so to conclude our decisions
demonstrate that the Commission will
sanction anti-competitive behavior in
e-commerce markets that empty to prevent
price competition between retailers
against the interests of consumers such
practices are serious violation of
European competition rules ecommerce
creates enormous possibilities for
consumers as well as for businesses in
principle consumers can from the sofa
back home find what they need and
compare prices from sellers all over
Europe so their choice isn't limited as
to what is on offer locally
similarly businesses can threat can
trade throughout our single market of
more than 500 million people using just
a single website as their shop window
but e-commerce
also brings challenges for a competition
and that is why the Commission did a
sector inquiry into eco into the
e-commerce sector we did that to
identify business practices that may
restrict competition this sector inquiry
confirmed that the use of pricing
algorithms to monitor and to influence
the price setting the behavior of others
well it is quite widespread we also find
found in the sector inquiry that more
than 1 in 10 surveyed retailers
experience cross-border sales
restriction in the distribution
agreements such restrictions
well they limit their ability to sell
online to consumers in other member
states specifically we are now looking
into concerns that guess naik Sanrio and
Universal Studios are restricting
cross-border and online sales of
products in distribution agreements
these investigation are ongoing and I
will of course not prejudge the outcome
to conclude through our competition
enforcement tool we will remain vigilant
to ensure that consumers are not harmed
when shopping that fee online or offline
thank you